[inaudible]
all right. I got behind this dump truck,
but this is one of my favorite
things on the road as far as, uh,
one of the best skylines you can
ever see. I mean, uh, Pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania, you go through this town
and you're like, oh, I, this looks like,
you know, shit all fucking titled
Smells like exhaust in here.
And uh, when you come through
the other tunnel though,
I'll show you the view here. This
is where you, people can't either,
you don't travel, but you know, vacations
in Pittsburgh, right? Let's be honest,
I didn't realize this tunnel
was this fucking long.
I'm running under shift the SEC. This
is like when there's like a rain delay,
they go back to two fucking
greenhorn announcers.
They run out of stories all day. They
already had a hot done here these
days. What time? Well, you know,
I was in the middle of
telling a story and yeah,
I guess I went to inhale as
I was swallowing in shelter.
Shut up fucking whore. I know what to
do. All right, so here we go. Well,
come on out. I see daylight,
I see things. All right,
so you coming through here, you're like,
whatever. Pittsburgh gives a flock,
right?
The hockey team with all that cheap shot
artists and that crybaby players, um,
Kabaka with you.
I respect him and all of a sudden
you come out of the tunnel and Bam,
you're going to ask, when
you see that, look at that.
There's hides field over there where the
fucking steel lattice would they play?
Can you see it? There's a
fucking guardrails in the way.
I think it's supposed to make
a left yet. Two 79 north.
Okay, sweetheart. We've
got all the bridges. Ah,
exit 70 p four 40
mention center. You know,
you're really fucked
up this video. Anyways,
that's one of my favorite
things in the road. Okay, bye.